alors là je vais revenir un petit peu
sur le contexte l'article 27 prévoit
qu'un défaut d'accord avant le premier
février 2023 entre l'assurance maladie
et les biologistes médicaux un arrêté
fixera une baisse pérenne de cotation
des actes de biologie médicale non liés
à la covid-19 devant générer une
économie de 250 millions d'euros dès
2023 donc c'est en fait une contribution
qui serait pérenne je veux dire qu'avant
il y avait des protocoles d'accord entre
l'assurance maladie et
l'élaboratoires et ça depuis 2014 et ça
fonctionnait très très bien seulement
entre temps on a eu la covid 19 et les
choses ont un petit peu changé il s'agit
donc là d'une proposition qui n'est rien
d'autre qu'un
ultimatum dont l'issue est une
diminution du remboursement des actes de
biologie qui affecteraient tous les
laboratoires et quel que soit leur
taille et quel que soit leur activité en
lieu et place de cette mesure
l'amendement de la commission propose de
créer une contribution exceptionnelle
assise sur les sommes versées en 2021
par l'assurance maladie et je voudrais
rappeler qu'en 2021 et bien ce
remboursement s'élevait à 2,7 milliards
d'euros et donc ce serait versé par
l'Assurance Maladie enfin cette somme
versée à l'assurance maladie au
laboratoire serait prise en compte à
charge du dépistage de la covid 19 cette
contribution serait seulement due en
2023 en contrepartie du chiffre
d'affaires réalisé par le secteur en
raison de la crise sanitaire elle serait
plus juste karakitée en proportion des
sommes reçus de l'assurance maladie et
en 2021 le remboursement donc devrait
s'élever avec un moment un amendement
qui propose de fixer le taux de la
contribution à
9,17%, et bien ça générer un produit de
250 millions d'euros
un rapporteur monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs et sénateurs madame la
rapporteur général
votre amendement propose de créer une
contribution exceptionnelle des
laboratoires de biologie médicale avant
toute chose il faut rappeler que
l'investissement des biologistes
médicaux durant la crise sanitaire a été
totale que en conséquence de cet
engagement leur chiffre d'affaires à lui
aussi augmenter en passant de 5,1
milliards d'euros à 9,4 milliards
d'euros entre 2019 et 2021 et que au
même moment le taux de rentabilité des
biologistes médicaux et à lui aussi
augmenter il est passé à plus de 30%
contre 16% en 2019
la solution proposée par le gouvernement
n'est pas sorti tout à fait du chapeau
puisqu'elle ait été négociée avec la
CNAM et les syndicats de biologie c'est
les discussions en d'ores et déjà
démarré c'est la raison pour laquelle la
solution qui est proposée par le
gouvernement nous y restons favorable et
que nous avons mon avis défavorable sur
la solution exceptionnelle que vous
proposez pour privilégier une solution
plus durable merci Monsieur Jassin
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues moi je soutiendrai
effectivement cet amendement qui est
beaucoup plus juste parce qu'en fait il
a une imposition sur un surplus de gains
mais effectivement on peut espérer que
le covid
ne va pas générer autant de dépenses et
je pense que la solution de madame le
rapporteur général est beaucoup plus
juste et en tout cas
cette cette solution de gouvernement
elle pourrait gêner des petits
laboratoires puisque c'est quelque chose
qui se perpéturait dans l'avenir et donc
elle pourrait gêner les petits
laboratoires notamment euro merci merci
oui monsieur le Président moi aussi je
soutiendrai récemment pour les mêmes
raisons j'ai été aussi contacté par des
laboratoires qui sont situés en milieu
rural parce que je suis élue dans un
département où il y a beaucoup de
petites communes et puis où la ruralité
est très présente et ils sont très
inquiets de ce qui est prévu par le
gouvernement ils ont de gros
investissements à faire aussi pour
rester au niveau et pour rester
compétitif avec les gros groupes de
laboratoires donc je soutiendrai aussi
cet amendement je vous remercie monsieur
Milon
oui merci Monsieur Président nous allons
évidemment soutenir l'amendement
présenté par par la rapporteur mais je
voudrais ajouter monsieur le ministre
que si vous vouliez à tout prix
récupérer de l'argent pour faire en
sorte que le pfss 2023 soit un moindre
dramatique que celui de 2022 il aurait
peut-être fallu à l'époque où vous avez
mis en place les tests et les vaccins
pensez à faire participer d'autres
organismes que la sécurité sociale et en
particulier les organismes qu'on appelle
okam s'ils n'ont pas participé du tout
puisque le gouvernement a décidé s'était
pris en charge intégralement ces
regrettable mais c'est plutôt de la
faute du gouvernement que de notre faute
à nous et du que de la faute des
laboratoires biologique en particulier
merci chers
oui moi je vais également soutenir
l'amendement de la présidente de la fin
de la rapporteur et de la commission des
affaires sociales je pense qu'il est
quand même plus juste de prélever une
taxe sur quelque chose d'exceptionnel
que d'instaurer une baisse des tarifs
pérennes en sachant que voilà la période
covid est derrière nous en tout cas on
l'espère
les chiffres sont clairs vous les avez
exposés monsieur le ministre le chiffre
d'affaires a presque doublé et la marge
aussi et donc c'est une argumentation
suffisamment claire pour voter
l'amendement de la rapporteur général je
vous remercie merci chers collègues donc
oui monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président simplement
pour rappeler que les chiffres que je
vous ai présentés ne nous semblent pas
être la simple résultante de l'épisode
de covid mais qui a bien une tendance
notamment à la concentration dans le
marché des biologistes médicaux qui va
conduire assez naturellement à une
progression de la marge qui appelle donc
des efforts complémentaires mais ces
efforts complémentaires ne sont pas
imposés ils sont négociés et comme je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure les discussions
entre la CNAM les bijustices médicaux
ont démarré
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc je mets
aux voix c'est amendement 37 de la
commission avec un vide défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté
[Musique]